in 2022 people were posting all kinds of
new ways to exercise on social media and
here to break it down for us is the
breakout star of his own shirts I'm
talking about Terry Crews
all right make him dance Terry make them
dance make them dance
what you got for us there Terry what are
we talking about well you know what was
crazy you know people think the workouts
I do are intense but you know I've never
seen anything like these look I don't
know what these people were thinking
about but look it's not working out
check this out
this dude turned daily exercise into his
daily exorcism you know what I mean the
power of Christ compels you oh yeah the
devil is in this man right now yeah back
oh man I ain't done bro yeah and seven
and you know how strong one that's all
I'm strong and high you gotta be at the
same time after all of that he go one
yeah
because you have to push yourself in the
gym but that's pushing it way too far
that's just a little crowd of crazy a
lot of nut slamming Am I Wrong oh my God
yeah the pelvis was on the ground the
pelvis was definitely on the floor
yeah very very aggressive what else you
got for us you know some people use gym
equipment this guy uses the gym as
equipment look at this thing
oh my God all right what are you doing
just do it regularly what are you doing
what are you doing no at this point they
got it's all been measured you don't
have to do that I'm gonna say no they're
gonna measure that out already all right
you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna take the time to say what
everybody wants to say but everybody's
afraid because this man is obviously in
amazing shape but somebody's got to say
sit your dumb ass down somebody said
sips somebody's got to say your dumb ass
down he's picking up a couch when the
the weight to his right is the exact
same thing exact measurement brother
what you doing I'm listening 310 well
then grab two of those goddamn dumbbells
that add up to the same amount who
chooses not to use gym equipment it uses
the [ __ ] around you in the gym for
people to sit on it's the stupidest
thing I've ever seen mad clunky that was
not smooth motion either no no that was
a shake weight 2.0 it was like
a good fall he needs to do that [ __ ] he
need a good fall he need one good fall
so somebody can go that's why like two
stupid ass you need to stop picking up
the [ __ ] with them bands and [ __ ] your
dumb ass in the corner yeah you need
that but really you got one more clip
right there yes I do most people work
out before their weddings not during
check this out okay
she didn't have no belt right you don't
recommend that
thank you for stopping by Terry man uh
we always appreciate you love you guys
man love you too Terry
[Music]